the kia most improved player of the year
huh brandon ingram well deserved yeah
you see his first three seasons and you
see what he did with
the new orleans pelicans this year
increasing up to 24 points
per game percentage is impressive and
he's
he hit more he hit more threes this
season
than the previous three seasons combined
and you know what folks we had a chance
to speak
with brandon amer
there was so much noise around the team
when you're in l.a
do you think finally getting traded to
new orleans and you can just concentrate
on basketball
that was a big difference for you
yeah i think so um you you
you live in la and you don't you kind of
don't know the distractions that's going
on and
um it's it's more than
about basketball going on around there
and i think going to new orleans
it was just all about basketball it was
so many genuine people there
everybody kept a room with me from day
one and
i just got to focus on basketball i
wasn't doing anything else but going
back to the gym every single day
you know brandon you win the most
improving uh player award
two things what was the things that you
think you've improved the most
in and what do you have to continue to
prove on
next year
well things i think i improved on the
most
leading by example owning off the
basketball floor
expanding my range out to the
three-point line i got a little more
comfortable out there and it
definitely held my game out a lot by
driving past slower defenders and
shooting over smaller defenders
and getting to the free-throw line and
knocking the free throws down having the
confidence there so
that was really good for me of course
to continue and to get better i think
for me to get stronger
in the areas that i need to get stronger
and
i think on the defensive side just
having the effort um at all times and
playing winning basketball and i think
that's the net stuff
just playing winning basketball brandon
what do you say to all the naysayers
that say yeah he's a fine player but he
needs to add 30 pounds of muscle
he needs to do this he needs to do that
so he can be the next kevin durant
what do you say to those people uh
i just say you can only be you you can
only be you
uh you know yourself more than people
other people do
go in put in the work whatever you need
is whatever you need and
uh continue to push whatever you want to
be in like go get it
brandon you know who i think is really
going to be happy
to hear this news about about the award
is jerry stackhouse tell me about
your days when he was coaching you in
aau ball
yeah um well it goes all the way back to
about 6th grade him coming down
every thanksgiving and him bringing his
brothers down his family down and
him playing against us in just the sixth
grade and
trying to teach us something giving us
advice and uh he just took me on his
wing i
started playing for his aau team um
he just kept talking to me then and
trying to get me in the right mindset to
to be where he was one day and it
definitely worked out
i stay in contact with him probably
every single week
and i probably keep it going he's got me
this far
i don't know how you got to do if you've
been talking to jerry every day but
that's all right jerry
you ain't doing you didn't do the job
you're supposed to do jerry he's
supposed to be in chapel hill
that's all i must say brandon ingram
thanks man we appreciate your time and
congratulations
thank you